a recipe for a recipe for oatmeal
cookies calls for two cups of flour for
every three cups of oatmeal how much
flour is needed for a big batch of
cookie that uses 9 cups of oatmeal so
let's think about what they're saying
they're saying two cups of flour so two
cups of flour two cups of flour flour
for every three cups of oatmeal for
every three cups of oatmeal for every
three cups of oatmeal so for every three
cups of oatmeal for every three cups of
oatmeal and so they're saying how much
flour is needed for a big batch of
cookies that uses 9 cups of oatmeal so
now we're going to a situation now we're
going to go to the situation where we
are using nine cups of oatmeal
let me write it this way 9 cups of
oatmeal 9 and I'll show you a couple of
different ways to think about it and
whatever works for you that's that that
works so first of all the one way to
think about it so we're wondering we're
going to say look we know if we have 3
cups of oatmeal we should use 2 cups of
flour but what we don't know is if we
have 9 cups of oatmeal how many cups of
flour do they use that's what they're
asking us but if we're going from 3 cups
of oatmeal to 9 cups of oatmeal
how much more oatmeal are we using well
we're using three times more oatmeal
right we're multiplying we're
multiplying by 3 3 cups of oatmeal 2 9
cups of oatmeal we're using three times
the oatmeal well if we want to use flour
in the same proportion we have to use
three times the flour so then we're also
gonna have to multiply the flour times
three we're going to multiply the flour
times three so we're going to have to
use 6 cups of flour we're going to have
to use six cups of ignore that question
mark 6 cups of flour another way you
could think about it that answers your
question that's how much flour we need
for a big batch of cookies that uses 9
cups of oatmeal the other thing is you
could set up a proportion you could say
you could say 2 cups 2 cups of flour
over 3 cups of oatmeal 3 cups of oatmeal
is equal to question mark and I'll say
instead of writing question mark I'll
put a variable in there I'll say is
equal to a question actually let me put
a question mark there just so you really
understand is equal to a question mark
in a box number cups of flour cups of
flour cups of flour over 9 cups of
oatmeal 9 cups of oatmeal and so I like
this first way we did it because it's
really just common sense if we're
tripling the the oatmeal then we're
going to have to triple the flour to
Matt to make the recipe in the same
proportion another way once you set up
an equation like this is actually to do
a little bit of algebra some people
might call it cross multiplying but that
cross multiplying is still using a
little bit of algebra and I'll show you
why they're really the same thing in
cross multiplication whenever you have a
proportion set up like this people will
represent will multiply the diagonals so
that when you multiply it we use cross
multiplication you'll say that 2 times 9
so 2 times 9 must be equal to question
mark times 3 must be equal to question
mark times 3 must be equal to whatever
is in this question mark the number of
cups of flour times 3 or we get 18 18 is
equal to whatever our question mark was
whatever our question mark was times 3
so the number of Klout cups of flours we
need to use times three needs to be
equal to 18 what times 3 is equal to 18
you might be able to do that in your
head that is 6 or you could divide both
sides by 3 and you will get 6 so we get
question mark in a box needs to be equal
to 6 cups of flour same answer we got
through kind of common sense now you
might be wondering hey this cross
multiplying doesn't make any intuitive
sense you know why does that work if I
have something set up like this
proportion set up why does it work that
if I if I take the denominator here and
multiply it by the numerator there that
that needs to be equal to the numerator
here times the denominator there and
that comes from straight-up algebra and
to do that I'm just going to rewrite
this part is X just to simplify the
writing a little bit so we have 2 over
three is equal to instead of that
question mark I'll write x over nine and
in algebra all you're saying is that
this quantity over here is equal to this
quantity over here so if you do anything
to the what's on the left if you want it
to still be equal if the thing on the
right still needs to be equal you'd have
to do the same thing to it and what we
want to do is we want to simplify this
so all we have on the right hand side is
an X so what can we multiply this by so
that we're just left with an X so that
we've solved for X well if we multiply
this times nine the nines are going to
cancel out so let's multiply the right
by nine but of course if we multiply the
right by nine we have to still multiply
the left by nine otherwise they still
wouldn't be equal if they were equal
before being multiplied by nine for them
to still be equal you have to multiply
nine times both sides on the right hand
side the 9s cancel out so you're just
left with an X on the left hand side you
have nine times two-thirds or nine over
one times two-thirds or this is equal to
eighteen over three and we know that 18
over three is the same thing as six so
these are all legitimate ways to do it I
want you to understand that what I'm
doing right here is algebra that's
actually the reasoning why cross
multiplication works but for a really
simple problem like this you could
really just use common sense if you're
increasing the cups of oatmeal by a
factor of three that increase the cups
of flour by a factor of three